Dr Doom was one of the most ridiculously  overpowered villains in the history of  Marvel Comics check this out so this guy  withstood a blast from Thanos using The  Infinity Gauntlet and suffered virtually  no damage to give you guys perspective  Thanos used The Infinity Gauntlet to  basically defeat the cosmic entities  this guy's stolen the power of the  beyonder who's basically the second most  powerful being in the Marvel Universe  next to God this guy's wielded the life  force which made him merely omnipotent  and with the aid of the molecule man in  Doctor Strange he stole the power of all  the beyonders he basically took what was  left of the Multiverse converted it down  into a singular Universe called battle  world he ripped thanos's spine out of  his body and disintegrated his entire  body he defeated an Infinity Gauntlet  wielding Black Panther and then killed  Cyclops when he had the Phoenix Force  this guy was broken as hell make sure  you follow for more